have you ever wondered which of Europe's
countries has the greenest energy supply
or which of its economies are growing
fastest or which organizations all not
be in the EU or how EU public funds are
being spent the EU gathers and generates
data about these and many other things
this data is like a digital echo of the
world around us which we can use to
improve our understanding of important
issues and to make better decisions the
European Commission's open data portal
gathers a huge range of data from
different eeew organizations and makes
it available in one central place for
anyone to use whether you're a
journalists looking to check some
figures or a policy researcher write in
a report or a developer creating a
useful website the portal is still under
development and we'll be adding more
data and new features in the coming
months if there's any data you think
should be there or a few good ideas for
new ways to use EU data we'd love to
hear from you get in touch
you